est-ce que vous pensez qu'un jour même
si c'est dans très longtemps bouche sera
condamné pour crime contre l'humanité
[Applaudissements]
pour moi c'est la continuité de Martin
Luther King moi le comics avec
c'est la continuité du message mais
actuel quoi ils ont inspiré tous les
grands groupes de rap c'est le plus
grand groupe traduire les frustrations
la colère de la communauté noire le
mieux oui mais surtout à travers le
monde c'est à dire que moi-même moi qui
suis ici quand je vais les clips de
public ennemi ça y est je voulais
comprendre ce que c'était ma culture ma
couleur mon c'est des messager c'est des
enfin voilà quoi et ça rappelle un peu
Jean Ferrat ils ont eu une audience ils
ont une audience énorme on disait que
vous étiez le vous disiez que vous étiez
le CNN noir
absolument oui tout à fait mais plus que
ça plus que ça parce qu'aujourd'hui il y
a une espèce de culture mondiale une
religion véritablement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'aime pas moi j'aime pas moi même
c'est pas ma carte
alors pas de pas de retraite pour vous
parce que vous dites le rap c'est pas un
métier c'est une passion donc pas
question de raccrocher les gants quoi
toujours toujours en continu maintenant
c'est un petit peu difficile
c'est-à-dire que vous allez regarder
tous les deux votre caméra celle qui a
le rouge et vous allez dire magnéto
Serge
reasphirst
manientool Serge
i don't like you
c'est pour ça que je t'aime bien
tu l'as fait star
s
trop cher
10000 dollars 10000 dollars
vous allez regarder votre caméra cette
caméra et il vous dites magnéto Serge
reasfirst magnéto Serge just real
ok one two three
vous pouvez expliquer comment vous êtes
passé d'une nouvelle ordre du monde aux
nouvelles odeurs mondiales
de confusion comme toutes les tentations
qui s'y trouvent
et alors ceux qui sont dans les
coulisses font des choses qui sentent
mauvais pour le monde d'où les mauvaises
odeurs d'où les mauvaises odeurs et
quand bouge je veux pas signer le
protocole de Kyoto ça procure des
mauvaises odeurs aussi
et puis en plus le gouvernement
américain il veut gouverner le monde
entier il veut un petit peu maîtriser
toute la planète mais ce jeu auquel il
joue entraîne lui aussi de bien mauvaise
odeur d'où les mauvaises odeurs
planétaires
c'est vrai que oui
c'est vrai que jazz bouge veut convertir
le monde à l'américanisme
il y a assez loin de ça
il veut que le Royaume-Uni soit le 51e
État de l'Union l'Australie le 52e État
de l'Union et la France de 53e étage
sera condamné pour crime contre
l'humanité
voilà je sais pas mais enfin
ce serait il faudrait que les Nations
Unies retrouvent leur sens parce que
c'est pas une question de savoir qu'un
grand pays soit contre des petits pays
tous les pays content les uns les autres
le Sénégal le Togo la France les Canada
tous ces pays doivent compter exactement
de la même façon parce que les êtres
humains c'est une seule race une seule
espèce
le monde ne devrait pas appartenir au
plus riche aux grosses multinationales
ou gros pays au milliardaire il y a des
gens en France dans les banlieues qui
veulent avoir l'occasion la possibilité
de vivre d'avoir une éducation comme
tout le monde les mêmes droits ils
veulent pas être les rats d'une grande
entreprise
[Applaudissements]
moi j'aimerais leur dire merci vraiment
merci pour tout ce qu'ils ont fait pour
la communauté pour le rap si gère un peu
aujourd'hui si je rappe aujourd'hui
c'est en partie grâce à eux parce que
grâce à tout ce qu'ils ont créé là-bas
ils ont réussi à nous passer le témoin
et nous on continue à perpétuer ces
choses là et il faut qu'on continue
qu'on continue qu'on continue
avec des questions à poser à check-ep
Eva j'aimerais voir leur demander des
nouvelles déterminateurs de professeur
griffes des Swan WW tous les si les
autres membres du groupe excuse-moi
Terminator X a pris sa retraite en 1989
il a été remplacé par DJ loot qui est
notre DJ ici Flavie flavour c'est de la
grosse super vedette à la télé
américaine aujourd'hui
et puis professeur écrit des bouquins il
donne des conférences pour vous c'est
qui aujourd'hui l'ennemi public numéro 1
Sarkozy
les États-Unis se détachent du reste du
monde
tous les Américains qui ont des
passeports ça veut dire que le reste ne
connaît pas le reste du monde et là je
trouve que c'est quand même
une centaine d'années je pense pas que
les pays seront les mêmes qu'aujourd'hui
vous aurez une grande masse d'être
humain et la question de savoir qui
gouverne qui à ce moment-là
et la trahison
merci et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu